je suis triste parce que jeudi soir nous
devions recevoir harry roselmack voilà
que j'aime beaucoup avec qui je suis à
ses potes et on s'entend très bien et
malheureusement suite à l' affaire tf1
harry roselmack ne sera pas là je dis
voilà il m'a laissé un très gentil
message il venait pour la promotion de
son long métrage intitulé fracture voilà
donc il n'a pas pu faire la promotion de
son film sur touche pas à mon poste
voilà ça nous a un petit peu peiné mais
saches voilà juste harry que je mettrais
quand même la bande annonce de ton film
puisque tu le mérites et que je t'aime
beaucoup en baba j'espère revenir
bientôt et je vous jure il a été
vraiment harris et voilà c'est un
exemple et m'a laissé un message m'a dit
cyril tu comprends voilà ça va mettre
dans une situation difficile et je le
comprends tout à fait et harry voilà ça
ce que je t'aime très fort et je vous
mettrais jeudi la bande-annonce de son
film qui a l'air vraiment exceptionnel
il fait un travail formidable
harry roselmack vraiment familial oui et
non je voulais dire à harry voilà avec
pour qui j'ai un âge où hilary pour qui
j'ai beaucoup de respect même même de
l'amitié
voilà qui va ne va pas céder au diktat
de tf1 qui va se reprendre avant avant
jeudi parce que voilà je trouve ce n'est
pas un petit soldat il ne l'approuvait
déjà de nombreuses reprises notamment
qu'elle ait refusé le joker éternelle du
jt donc là j'aimerais bien qu'ils ne
portent pas l'uniforme une guerre qui
n'est pas la sienne pour la tf 1 et
c'est absolument au détriment de son
film cette fois ci de faire mousser une
affaire qui n'en est pas une
dans la seule dans le seul objectif de
porter devant grâce à cette émission là
donc à rip site où l'on regarde ne gêne
pas qu'on filme kiamo bébé avec l'eau du
bain
ici
plus de joueurs quittent ani 6-4 à
former un bloc très fort mais
franchement on lui en veut pas arriver
et si il a l'interdiction de venir on
veut pas le foot dans la merde bien
entendu parce qu'on aime beaucoup